l'arrivée de l'automne rappelle que
c'est ici que tout a commencé que c'est
ici que le mot terrorisme a soudainement
pris une dimension aux canadiennes à
quelques pas du tout a été fauchée
l'adjudant patrice vincent on en parle
comme si c'était arrivé hier sa première
fois quand ces gens il ya une chose
comme ça ça n'a pas de bon sens on y
pense on sait que ça existe c'est que
les possibilités que ça s'est reproduit
son lors dans une ville où il existe une
longue tradition aux militaires la
question de la sécurité a toujours eu
une résonance particulière aux mois
après l'attentât
difficile d'oublier ce qui s'est produit
ici
après midi deux parties carte à la
région de saint-jean-sur-richelieu des
vétérans de tout âge et leurs proches
viennent régulièrement y faire leur tour
les opinions sur la sécurité sont toutes
aussi variées que leur stratégie
non l'état rangera pas les soucis à quoi
ça peut ça peut devenir un de pire en
pire
ça ne peut faire part mais je me dis
nous arriver mais je me sens en sécurité
tout autant que n'importe quel autre
canadien mais faut quand même être
vigilant
ils sont conscients de l'évolution du
débat sur la sécurité tout comme de
l'entrée en vigueur de la loi
antiterroriste
ce code de sécurité
ça nous donne confiance aux quais de la
protection c'est bien certain mais
encore là tous n'ont pas la même vision
des choses avec ce bébé là on sait pas
jusqu'où ça pourrait aller on se pose
des questions à savoir qui va contrôler
quoi il ya des grosses questions accord
à ce transport
elle devra être modifiée par pape pas
aboli mais vos dossiers
les risques d'atteinte à la vie privée
des canadiens en dérange certains pour
d'autres la loi antiterroriste reflète
la réalité d'aujourd'hui
ce que ça va trop loin quand vous de
tout ce qui se passe et ce qui est
arrivé à ottawa et faut pas garder que
le pays et non plus sur la garde à
l'extérieur fait dix ans que la france
risque est élevé est vrai que ça pendant
la chine juste milieu mais qu'est ce que
vous voulez ils ont vécu de près le même
événement et pourtant d'une table à
l'autre
la loi c 51 rassure autant qu'elle
soulève des craintes
et si marc godbout radio-canada saint
jean sur richelieu